so inside and outside are  of course interlinked  you can't create an inside without  shaping the outside and the link  provides a transition between inside and  outside  concave spaces make it feel like you're  inside and convex spaces make it feel  like you're outside  straight corners are used to create a  more defined space  and round corners make the space feel  more spacious because the boundaries are  harder to perceive but  boundaries don't necessarily have to be  defined with walls you can define  boundaries with landscape elements like  bushes or benches or rocks  like in this instance we don't have any  walls but  you can still see that the boundaries  are pretty clearly defined and it really  feels like its own enclosed space